let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 remember to listen for your area code
you won't hear a click or beep when we
put you on our first caller is from the
603 area code caller from 603 what is
that New Hampshire yeah who's this God
Jake Jake what's on your mind today well
I actually have a few questions well be
brief
now the first is the economy you know
there's been kind of a little bit of a
correction and you know I'm just curious
about how you think the economy's gonna
play into 2018 and then I'm also curious
if you if you believe that memo the
memos did come out and everything that's
being pushed by you know some of the
House Republicans that's now being
seized by some middle-of-the-road
conservatives like I don't know if you
saw Ben Shapiro's reaction so just kind
of under the year what you had to say
about that okay so the memo I've covered
extensively I think basically it does
nothing to discredit Robert Moeller's
investigation which should be allowed to
continue
period yeah I've spoken pretty
extensively about it the economy is an
interesting question and the truth is
that we're not good at predicting what
the economy is going to do first and
foremost I've said before the stock
market alone is not a good indicator of
how the economy is doing is one part of
it
Trump has chosen to sort of live by the
stock market so that follows it follows
from that that he should also die by the
stock market if the stock market goes
down that's only one piece of the total
economy a big part of the economy is one
that's not usually discussed which is if
you look at inequality the difference
between in terms of income and wealth
the top and the bottom and the average
if there's huge levels of inequality
that's an indicator that the economy is
not working super well for a lot of
people and you're not going to
necessarily see that in employment
numbers even the average wage won't
necessarily address that particular
issue so 28 Ryan was your question
that's pretty soon right I mean it's
like a lot of people vote based on news
around the
appointment rate and the stock market so
that that'll have an impact but I think
anyone who's trying to predict exactly
how the economy will be doing we know
that economists are barely better at
predicting that than just random people
it seems like right now especially in
the market across the board there's a
lot of insecurity and no one's really
sure whether or not this is a correction
or if it's going to stabilize and
continue to rise and I figure that the
Democrats you know they need to
capitalize on the reality of the economy
as opposed to just watching charts sure
it's just very tough because when you
have something that people don't
necessarily understand the meaning of
that much like people say oh the stock
market up I guess it's good down is bad
even though most stocks are held by a
small portion of the people in the in
the country anyway it's very easy to
trick those people based on story lines
and talking points that nobody really
understands anyway you know what I mean
Jake but yes yes yes and I wish that we
could you know find a way to echo
inequality and those relatives those
relevant rather yeah points of the
economy instead of trying to argue
against the stock market III absolutely
can't stand listening to my liberal
friends here when the stock market does
poorly that that's just yeah listen I
don't know who your friend is but I've
not actually heard anyone like you know
I'm I'm a preneur I mean I guess hearing
a lot that's an embellishment Oh but so
that was you know I meant more just you
know there is the the true progressives
in this country they need to get behind
the economic realities yes I believe and
you know yeah III would argue the
progressives are behind one of those
realities and recognizing that
inequality is a problem all right Jake
thanks very much appreciate the call